welcome back vaccine eligibility is
expanding here in nevada starting next
week
on monday anyone 16 and older will be
eligible to receive the covet 19 vaccine
and this morning senators jackie rosen
and catherine cortez-masto made a visit
to a major vaccination site here in las
vegas our bianca holman reports
moderna pfizer and johnson and johnson
kova 19 vaccines are all given here at
the cashman center
it's an example of the coordinated
effort between federal
state and local authorities senators
rosen and cortez masto got a look inside
at the site
escorted by leaders from the health
district fire department and fema
those who were vaccinated in the
observation section listened to the
henderson symphony
and spoke with the senators people
shared their good and bad moments during
the pandemic
one woman experiencing job loss and a
first-time father
raising a baby these senators say
vaccines are essential not only to save
lives but also to get our economy
back on track this site is proof
to our travelers that want to come back
to las vegas that we want
those over what 50 million visitors that
we're safe and we can do this safely
we can do it safely here we can work
with our properties we can work with our
businesses
to really make sure people feel
comfortable and safe the vaccine is free
of charge but you must make an
appointment
our state's timeline to make the vaccine
available to all adults is in line and
ahead of president joe biden's challenge
to have vaccines available for all
adults by may 1st
and you can make an appointment to
receive the covet 19 vaccine on the
southern nevada health district's
website
bialcoholman 8 news now